Давай, рівно до кутика приставляй.
Дякую.
У 2008 році витинанка вважалась
вимираючим видом мистецтва в Україні.
Тому що це папір, це не зберігається.
Вчителями витинанки я вважаю своїх батьків.
Мама, наприклад, мене вчила
не обмежуватися сніжинками.
Я просто почала брати великі формати
і цим, можна сказати, привернула увагу.
Робимо верх: це для планки.
Я це все якось сама собі придумала,
щоб воно витримувало
якісь навантаження і ще щось.
Тобто тут правильно треба розвантажити витнуті шматочки
і мереживо, яке буде одне з одним сплітатися.
І це якась схема, яку я собі придумала.
Хоча зараз уже з'явилося багато плагіаторів,
які думають, що це завжди було,
що це колись так робили.
Мене дуже часто тягне на різні сучасні проєкти,
але, все ж таки, оці народні, традиційні
символи настільки глибоко
сидять десь у мені,
що я навіть як щось намагаюся
зробити суперабстрактне,
все одно вилазить якийсь український мотив.
Але дуже боялась,
щоб воно не було якоюсь шароварщиною.
Проте воно б настільки зайшло,
що всі визнали, що воно може бути
на межі сучасного і
нести традиційну автентику.
Це не папір.
Це я зробила такий винахід — це синтетичний матеріал,
банерне полотно.
Яке витримує сніг, дощ,
і здалека воно має вигляд як папір.
В Україні спершу мені було важко із цим папером,
бо люди бояться купувати його собі до інтер'єру.
«Як, це ж не вічне, воно мені може порватись».
Мені дуже подобається воно на вікнах,
бо на великих і гарних вікнах воно має вигляд як вітражі.
Я не знаю якихось суперавтентичних
мотивів або методів.
В принципі, це все дуже просте,
бо папір доступний.
І цього може навчитися кожна господиня,
кожен господар.
Для мами з дітьми,
яка має зробити тисячу справ:
завести в садок, привести, нагодувати,
почистити картоплю, і ще щось, і ще щось,
то витинанка  — це рятівна моя штука,
яка врятувала мою творчість.
Три види, чим можна це робити.
Це можна робити руками,
можна робити ножицями і  ножем.
Руками — це називається вириванка.
Тобто ми беремо папір,
пом'якшуємо його фактуру.
Витинанка завжди, як мене навчили, має бути симетрична.
Тобто ми папір маємо скласти.
Також наносимо малюнок олівцем.
Ми, наприклад, наносимо тут якесь схематичне зображення.
І руки у нас відіграють роль ножиць.
Тобто ось, наприклад, берегиня.
Дуже цікаво завжди це дітям роботи,
бо це психологічне розвантаження.
І така розминка.
Потім — ножиці.
Також складаємо.
Я от, коли складаю саме папір,
то для мене це дуже таке...
Я бачу в цьому своєрідну магію,
бо коли розкриваєш — ти знаєш що вийде.
Ну ось наприклад,
ножицями ми зробили ангелика.
Наприклад, на Різдво або Великдень.
Можна робити таких багато білих і буде такий настрій.
Техніка витинання ножем.
Так само наносимо половинку зображення.
Я досить часто роблю мотиви із зображенням жінки,
мені чогось так хочеться,
вилазять з мене якісь жіночі образи.
Тобто якісь такі традиційні мотиви,
напевно, заклались ще
коли я вчилась на художньому ткацтві
у Вижницькому коледжі.
Ми там вивчали килимарство, вивчали гобелени.
І, можна сказати,
що зараз це все мені допомагає
у витинанці.
Зараз так легко цим займатися,
бо вже є всі матеріали, які для цього потрібні.
Ну, наприклад, бачимо якесь таке зображення.
Головне — не боятися того паперу,
бо багато хто боїться.
«Ой, я зараз зіпсую!»
Але насправді його треба якось так відчути.
Я вважаю, що папір має душу, він такий... живий.
Ці три витинанки зроблено якраз спеціально для бібліотеки.
На твори Романа Іваничука.
Це є його роман «Мальви».
Є багато заплетених мотивів, які важко побачити.
Тут, наприклад, є алфавіт.
Якщо придивитися, то тут можна побачити буквочки.
Тут напис «бібліотека на ринку», суто як їхнє лого.
Дуже важко було зробити,
бо така була ідея, зробити у формі відкритих дверей.
І третя робота,
теж такий вислів Іваничука:
«В цій землі зарита твоя пуповина».
На твір «Манускрипт».
Ніби такий манускрипт скручений,
і така оранта.
Ніби символізує соборність України.
Я дуже тішусь, що знайшла себе в цьому,
бо маю якусь таку, можливо, від тата,
якусь таку всередині штуку,
що я мушу реалізовуватися.
Тоді я відчуваю себе повністю щасливою.